so tell them how to summon the Saiyan
God long ago a small group of pure
hearted Saiyans question the evil
committed by their race the good sales
decided to lead a revolt against the man
and to ensure victory pooled their
powers to create a savior a Super Saiyan
God the Savior easily defeated the evil
Saiyans with this immense power but he
then vanished as quickly as he came as
the energy the Saiyans had offered him
could not last for long in time evil
again took root on planet Vegeta and the
memory of the Super Saiyan God became
myth nearly lost altogether hey
everybody it's Charlie I've got a lot of
requests to do a new Dragon Ball super
videos so they're really like two big
theories about who the villain of the
Dragon Ball super movie is going to be
based on the events of the tournament of
power during the Dragon Ball super
series so if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I will do Dragon Ball
super and I will be doing videos for the
new series in the movie whenever that
comes we still don't have a whole lot of
details about what the follow-up series
is going to be - Dragon Ball super only
the next year is their 20th anniversary
so there's probably going to be
something happening next year they're
really two competing theories but they
all revolve around the resurrection of
universe 6 at the end of the tournament
of power you have 17 using the super
Dragon Balls wish to resurrect all
universes that had previously been
destroyed now that's a bit of a separate
theory - because we can at least assume
that all the universes that were
destroyed during the course of the
tournament had been brought back like
universe 6 but also because it was a
super Dragon Ball which not just a
Dragon Ball but a super Dragon Ball that
maybe the older universes that were
destroyed a long time ago way before the
tournament were also resurrected I
should probably do a separate video
about that but the actual villain of the
Dragon Ball movie looks a lot like it
might be either the Saiyan God or the
legendary super sand which kind of for
the same people is almost like the final
form of Super Saiyans the two competing
theories being mo she
or Broly i thinkyou moshe is a little
more likely but both of them get tied up
in the idea of legendary Saiyan form
which gives off that greenish glow the
person in the trailer is giving off a
greenish glow so it looks like whoever
he's fighting it is like the final form
of sands which is like the ultimate
Saiyan form before you become an actual
God and I think that the creator
actually said a long time ago that he
would never turn Goku into a God so the
next big step for him if he were not
going to become a God would be legendary
Saiyan form he could unlock this during
a fight with someone who also has that
ability because the whole idea of why
Goku needs to level up into another
Saiyan form is because his current form
whatever it is during any given fight
isn't powerful enough so all signs just
point towards the next level being
legendary saying let me know in the
comments if you actually think this is
mo she because there are a lot of
questions about his history there were a
couple moments during the tournament of
power that hinted that they might be
bringing him back at some point
beerus saw that vision of him when they
were destroying the universe he's the
same god of universe 6 now that all the
universes are coming back that were
destroyed during the tournament it seems
like they're going to the planet of the
original sands which is in that universe
goku looks really excited when he's
getting ready to fight this person which
character within the Dragon Balls story
universe would he be more excited to
fight than the very first same
but if there were a way to achieve such
power I should know it I am the Prince
of all Saiyans if there is to be a new
super saiyan it should be me via the
really cool thing about that too is in
telling the story of the origin of the
sands in bringing back universe 6 also
helps set up a next Dragon Ball series
arc now we don't have a name for that
but a lot of people have theorized is
that now that universe 6 is back Goku
and these are the people will go to
train the new sands that had been
resurrected the series wasn't quite as
explicit as the manga was about beerus
having this dream but fighting his
greatest enemy so it just seems like
when he's watching this happening he's
seeing the Super Saiyan God because
wouldn't you need to be a god to fight
one of the gods of destruction or at
least as powerful as one well I thought
against the Super Saiyan God who looks
just like this one a premonition boy
disorder did you come
so also let me know in the comments do
you actually think that he was seeing
emotion he was seeing this form here
because it's meant to be kind of
ambiguous but I think it's all pointing
towards this Dragon Ball movie I think
they were they were trying to set this
up but also another big question - like
what do you expect them to do for the
20th anniversary next year there was a
teaser for the tour that they're going
on there's going to a couple different
cities so New Year is totally an idea
Nina you are Canadian top
[Music]
[Applause]
but just leave all your requests for
Dragonball videos in the comments below
like I said we'll be doing Dragonball
until the movie gets here and then
whatever the next series comes I'm
totally down to do episode videos for
that really wish I would have known that
so many of my subscribers were fan of
this series I would have done it sooner
but why you wait for everything click
here for my Dragon Ball super
finale video and click here for that
brand new Deadpool animated series
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]